sans public continu avec notre semaine
spéciale énergie hier ont des battait de
l'avenir du nucléaire demandez couvrira
les énergies du futur et ce soir on
ouvre le dossier et au lien brique
indispensable de la transition
écologique pour les uns aberrations
visuelles sonores et économique pour les
autres avant d'entendre nos experts cet
artage que je vous propose tout de suite
à Saint-Nazaire c'est là que Emmanuel
Macron a inauguré le mois dernier le
premier parc éolien maritime de France
il produira 20% de la consommation
énergétique de
Loire-Atlantique reportage signé Audrey
il faut faire 15 km de bateau pour
rapprocher ses 80 géants d'acier de 210
mètres de haut nous sommes au large de
Saint-Nazaire au milieu du tout premier
parc éolien offshore de France qui voit
enfin le jour après 14 longues années de
projet et plus de 2500 réunions
publiques à terme il produira 20% de la
consommation électrique du département
de Loire-Atlantique on avait un grand
nombre de défis sur le sur le parc
éolien des défis techniques et des défis
qui n'échappent à personne c'était que
c'est le premier parc éolien en maire de
France donc effectivement on est on a je
dirais ouvert beaucoup de voix que ce
soit réglementaire humaine arriver à
inscrire un parc éolien dans un horizon
de vie c'est quelque chose qui prend du
temps la réalité aujourd'hui est visible
elle est bien évidemment et j'en suis
très heureux conforme à ce qui avait été
imaginé il y a des années Emmanuel
Macron lui même en sur ce tout nouveau
parc a salué un jour heureux avant
d'annoncer une accélération de la France
sur l'éolien en mer le président
voudrait 50 parcs comme celui-ci d'ici
2050 et il y a beaucoup d'enseignements
attirés du chantier de Saint-Nazaire sur
l'environnement d'abord les associations
de protection de la nature disent avoir
été écoutés notamment sur le métal
utilisé pour protéger l'éolienne sous
l'eau le premier sélectionné était
toxique pour laisser tasser et donc on a
changé de méthodologie EDF à accepter de
changer méthodologie au vu des alertes
portées par les gens des cétacés et la
pêche donc on a été relativement entendu
et on a bien été dans la réduction des
impacts aurait constitué à ne pas faire
le parc
la prévention a quand même été de
prendre en compte ses impacts et de
créer des alternatives
c'était un chantier pilote je dirais
modèle on verra si le modèle est suivi
et si on peut améliorer le modèle la
petite commune touristique de basse sur
mer a aussi des idées pour améliorer le
modèle son paysage est l'un des plus
chamboulés par les éoliennes sur ce qui
s'appelait la côte sauvage on les voit
beaucoup sur le paysage ça impacte
énormément
je dirais même la nuit plus que dans la
journée parce que la nuit il y a des
petits clignotants rouges ou blanc mais
comme un comble base sur mer et l'une
des municipalités qui percevra le moins
d'aide compensatoire car elles sont
calculées sur le Nombre d'habitants à
l'année
2880 contre 18000 l'été la commune
compte de très nombreuses résidences
secondaires qui ne sont pas prises en
compte dans les indemnités le parc
éolien en soi et c'est une très bonne
chose la seule chose que je regrette
c'est les indemnisations moi j'espère
simplement que l'horloge va peut-être
être un peu plus importante et
contiendra compte effectivement de des
résidences secondaires
voilà pour que ce soit un petit peu plus
juste quoi le président a promis que la
question des indemnités serait repensée
dans le projet de loi énergie
renouvelable qui arrive au Parlement
notre semaine spéciale énergie dans
Sciences publiques je vous présente les
invités de ce débat Françoise Gatel
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice
Union centriste d'Ille-et-Vilaine Renan
Dantec bonsoir sénateur du groupe
écologiste de Loire-Atlantique sénateurs
de Loire-Atlantique Michel joria bonjour
bonsoir bienvenue délégué général de
France énergie éolienne avec nous
également en duplex Jean-Marie virly qui
émerge des poisses départements
Côte-d'Or dans la région Bourgogne
Franche-Comté on va avoir votre vécu des
Luc local Mathieu croissando éditoris
politique évidemment est resté à mes
côtés peut-être pour commencer une
réaction à notre reportage donc sur
l'éolien offshore ou l'éolien maritime
en bon français
Françoise Gatel vous dites quoi enfin la
France rattrape son retard ou alors
attention au déploiement de cette éolien
maritime
attention déploiement tout court parce
que je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est
confronté à beaucoup de tensions à part
des élus locaux la population se rejette
parce que on a un vrai problème c'est à
dire on laisse les choses se faire au
fil du temps parce qu'il y a aussi des
opportunités
financières pour un certain nombre
d'opérateurs et de propriétaires enfin
en tout cas sur l'éolienne
sur terre et on n'a pas de stratégie et
que donc on se crée un tas de difficulté
et moi j'espère que la loi qui arrive va
permettre d'avoir une vraie stratégie de
développement à une échelle qui soit
pertinente qui est beaucoup de pédagogie
et d'explications auprès des élus locaux
notamment les mers qui se retrouvent
entre l'enclume et le marteau et qui
prennent un peu des coups de la part de
tout le monde soit les favorable aux
éoliennes ou ceux qui ne le sont pas sur
le terrain c'est effectivement souvent
source de de tension même à l'intérieur
même des amis parmi les habitants d'une
même ville Renault nantais que la France
je reste sur les auréens Maritimes pour
l'instant elle reste très en retard de
par si on regarde les voisins
britanniques allemands belges
néerlandais
euh c'est pourquoi comment ça s'explique
on a fait les choses à l'envers c'est
quoi le pardonisme je crois que la
France était enferré dans dans le mythe
du nucléaire amis effectivement dans la
capacité d'investissement économique
nationale dans le nucléaire et n'a pas
vu que le monde avait changé et qu'on se
retrouve aujourd'hui nous avec une
électricité intermittente ça s'appelle
le nucléaire la moitié des réacteurs en
rade et que on a ailleurs aujourd'hui il
faut les derniers parcs maritimes danois
c'est 42 euros le mégawattheure si on ne
rattrape pas le retard les électrons
intensifs français partiront ou
achèteront de l'électricité venant
d'écosses ou du nord de l'Europe et
jamais même avec les réacteurs dans
15-20 ans on ne produira c'est arrivé là
donc c'est vraiment l'avenir de
l'industrie française qui est en train
de se jouer dans le fait de rattraper le
retard notamment sur l'éolien maritime
je voudrais revenir sur la méthode
Michel joria parce que
je crois savoir que les Britanniques ils
ont commencé par définir tout à fait
nationalement toutes les zones où on
pourrait développer l'éolien maritime
c'est-à-dire consultation des riverains
des élus
grands publics en quelque sorte avant de
donner les concessions aux entreprises
et c'est pas du tout ce qu'on fait en
France c'est pas du tout ce qu'on sait
en France et nous c'est ce qu'on appelle
de nouveau depuis plus années puisqu'en
fait quand on regarde l'explication du
retard français puisque effectivement au
cours des 10 dernières années 5700
éoliennes ont été installés en Europe
Royaume-Uni Danemark Belgique Pays-Bas
donc en Europe 5700 en mer du coup et en
fait la grosse différence et la
planification donc c'est un mot qu'on
avait oublié c'est quelque chose qu'on a
su parfaitement faire jusqu'au milieu
des années 80 sur tout un tas de sujets
en France le TGV Internet le ministère
la fibre encore récemment et en fait sur
les énergies renouvelables et
globalement sur la transition
énergétique on ne l'a pas fait parce
qu'en fait quand on regarde bien tous
les toutes les composantes de la
politique énergétique française
aujourd'hui sont en retard en retard sur
l'efficacité énergétique à la sobriété
on est en retard sur toutes les énergies
renouvelables et on est en retard sur le
nouveau nucléaire donc en fait on peut
même pas dire à un moment donné il y a
quelque chose qu'on a réussi non on est
en retard sur tout donc sur l'éolien en
mer nous ce qu'on demande et pour le
coup c'est important parce que la loi
d'accélération le met en avant on
demande de définir finement et pas pour
5 ans pour 15 ans pour donner de la
visibilité à tout le monde dire bah
voilà en fait pour des questions
environnementales quand on croise les
pêcheurs le transport maritime le
tourisme les questions de raccordement
les 20 parcs qui va falloir qu'on
construisent en 2035 et les 50 d'ici
2050 où on doit les mettre et pourquoi
mais Françoise Gatel si on essaye de
prendre des peut-être dans votre
département d'Ille-et-Vilaine cette
histoire de concertation de d'ordre des
choses vous voyez avant de lancer un
projet d'éolien par exemple d'éolien
maritimes est-ce que c'est forcément
est-ce que la consultation est
suffisante quoi sur quelle expérience
vous pouvez vous accrocher pour nous
dire ça marche ou marche pas mais je
pense que la concertation elle est
indispensable nécessaire en Bretagne on
a le parc éolien de Saint-Brieuc parce
que les choses durent très longtemps
qu'on n'a pas expliqué aux gens l'enjeu
des énergies renouvelables efficacité ce
que ça allait produire et qu'on fait les
choses comme ça il y a pas
d'acceptabilité et c'est exactement ce
que vous disiez c'est à dire je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on se paye des problèmes
insolubles parfois de la part de la
population et des élus parce qu'on n'a
pas expliqué on n'a pas de stratégie le
jour où on a électrifié ce pays enfin
moi j'étais panée mais il y a bien
quelqu'un qui a dit qu'il y a un modèle
de développement voilà comment on le
fait voilà jusqu'où on va aller à quoi
ça sert or aujourd'hui et on va voir
dans les débats qui vont avoir lieu au
Sénat comment on va se retrouver en
pétrer par des mini problème qu'on s'est
causés parce que on n'a pas de la
méthode qu'il fallait et on va voir les
questions des élus locaux qui vont dire
ah non non mais moi je veux un droit de
veto etc on va en parler évidemment
voilà et donc je pense qu'il est urgent
aujourd'hui alors moi j'aime bien
regarder les manières de les choses de
manière positive maintenant posons-nous
il y a ce projet de loi qui j'espère va
nous amener à moi une stratégie une
planification à accélérer avoir de
l'acceptabilité
j'élargi on a passé un peu de temps sur
le maritime mais là le l'éolien en
général et on va plus se concentrer sur
les reins terrestres et je me tourne
vers Jean-Marie virly voilà je rappelle
que vous êtes mère des poisses dans
votre ville et peut-être autour
en Côte-d'Or
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup d'éoliennes
aujourd'hui c'est quoi la situation et
l'acceptation parce qu'on est sur cette
cette question là alors dans d'autres
secteur effectivement on a beaucoup
d'éoliennes
en particulier l'Yonne et le nord du
Côte-d'Or des éoliennes qui sont situées
et on en a maintenant des centaines bien
évidemment et vous venez de parler de
l'acceptabilité l'acceptabilité évolue
énormément de ces derniers mois donc
simplement parce que comme ça vient
d'être dit il y a juste titre on n'a pas
assez expliqué et surtout les
explications étaient un petit peu
fausses a priori alors je vais vous
donner quelques exemples on nous a dit
il faut mettre des éoliennes faut
accepter des aliens parce qu'on a besoin
d'électricité et on nous explique
maintenant que on n'a pas avoir
d'électricité et qu'on va passer un
hiver difficile donc il faut faire faut
comprendre que c'est pas très simple à
accepter a priori et on est dans cette
difficulté d'explication et aujourd'hui
la population un peu retournée et
l'acceptabilité qui avait été un peu
plus ou moins forcé pour des problèmes
financiers il y a quelques années
aujourd'hui les populations se révoltent
et ne comprennent plus peu très bien
je vais vous redonner la parole une fois
dans ce débat évidemment mais est-ce
qu'il y a un côté un peu la campagne
contre les villes c'est est-ce que vous
vous réclamez une meilleure répartition
territoriale de ces éoliennes bien sûr
c'est tout à fait évident de ce qu'on
comprend c'est pas méchant ce que je
vais dire mais on voit bien que les
décisions sont pris par des gens de la
ville et qui imposent des décisions à la
campagne donc on est toujours nous en
train de se dire attendez c'est
peut-être à nous de savoir un petit peu
où est-ce qu'il faut les mettre et si on
a besoin de les mettre à priori sachant
que je le répète les informations et les
explications ont toujours été énormément
erronées je vais vous donner un deuxième
exemple si vous voyez on nous explique
que si vous installez un parc éolien sur
votre commune vous allez pouvoir
alimenter en électricité 1000 2000 3000
personnes suivant la capacité installée
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on constate
avec le constate qu'on n'a pas à nous
couper l'électricité dans nos villages
donc les gens on n'aura pas expliqué ce
que ça voulait dire et évidemment il se
révolte en disant attendez c'est au
confond la puissance et on confonds il y
a une part de conjoncturelle qu'elle y a
la crise énergétique actuelle et puis il
y a les questions beaucoup plus
structurales j'en grâce à vous dans un
instant pardon de vous interrompre
Jean-Marie Viry mais je vous redonnerai
la parole évidemment plusieurs fois ce
qui on va se poser un peu à un instant
Mathieu pour pour voir que que et
peut-être que ça complique d'ailleurs
sérieusement les choses les éoliennes
c'est devenu un enjeu du débat politique
national oui parce que elles ont
toujours été un débat au plan local on
le voit bien mais elles sont devenus en
quelques années un sujet de polémique
qui a même fait éruption dans la
dernière campagne présidentielle et
c'est devenu un sujet de débat et
d'empoignade national le premier parti à
son saisir ça a été le Front national de
rassemblant national qui est parti vend
debout si j'ose dire contre les
éoliennes dès les premières
implantations en disant il est
inconcevable de détruire au nom de
l'écologie le cadre de vie de nos
concitoyens voilà ça ça a été le le
mantra de Marine Le Pen qui jugé
également les éoliennes inefficaces et
contre-productive à l'automne 2021 elle
est à l'époque candidate du
Rassemblement National à la
présidentielle elle revendique une
écologie de la joie de vivre je le
rappelle et elle promet un moratoire et
annonce son souhait de démonter les
éoliennes alors la nouvelle fait
polémique une association soulignent le
coup astronomique de l'opération le côté
complètement contre intuitif et doute
même de sa faisabilité et elle qu'est-ce
qu'elle dit un open elle précise dans
son programme nous lancerons le
démantèlement progressif des sites en
commençant par ceux qui arrivent en fin
de vie petite phrase qui je trouve
ressemble énormément à ce que disent les
opposants nucléaires et qui disent au
démantèlera les centrales en commençant
par les plus vieilles voilà celles qui
sont en fin de vie jusqu'au bout en fait
elle en fera un thème de campagne un
argument de campagne quitte à se prendre
les pieds un peu dans le tapis lors de
son débat d'entre deux tours vous vous
souvenez face à Emmanuel Macron elle
reprochera au président de la République
de vouloir mettre des éoliennes en mer
partout sur toutes les côtes sauf en
face du Touquet ou le couple présentiel
possède possède sa résidence secondaire
et à propos qui sera démenti d'ailleurs
par le maire de la commune LR daniel
Fasquelle alors Marine Le Pen elle a
peut-être été la première mais c'est pas
la seule on aura fait un cheval de
bataille non parce que Killian en
boitait le pas derrière une très grande
partie de la droite des républicains
Xavier Bertrand en tête en souviens l'an
dernier qui est confronté dans les
Hauts-de-France mais comme d'autres
présidents de région ou encore Éric
Zemmour qu'on avait fait sa bête noire
je veux dire tout le mal que je pense
des moyenne à la fois pour la santé des
gens à la fois pour la beauté des
paysages elle disait le polémiste qu'il
est qualifie de catastrophes encore
aujourd'hui et du coup les colonnes
l'éolienne est devenue une certaine
façon je trouve un marqueur politique
c'est si vous êtes de gauche vous êtes
forcément pour les éoliennes vous êtes
de droite vous êtes en train de devenir
forcément contre les éoliennes pourquoi
cet acharnement il y a les arguments
qu'on a cité sur la dénaturation des
paysages sur la remise en cause de leur
efficacité à cause de leur intermittence
mais aussi sur la critique de leur court
environnemental c'est quelque chose qui
revient souvent les matériaux qu'on
utilise pour les construire mais au-delà
de leur seule fonction je trouve le
combat contre l'éolienne est devenu un
symbole vous l'avez dit un peu celui des
petits qui n'ont pas leur mot à dire
contre les gros qui décident celui des
campagnes contre les villes celui
évidemment des ruraux contre Paris enfin
province capitale région capital celui
de la défense du terroir du patrimoine
celui de la France d'hier qui rassure
contre celle de demain qui fait peur
bref une sauce de source d'énergie
renouvelable l'éolienne est devenue un
moulin avant populiste d'une certaine
façon pour certains
et c'est assez inquiétant Michel joria
vous êtes au cœur de ce combat
finalement tout à fait ça complique
est-ce que est-ce que je disais le plus
plus ça devient national plus c'est
compliqué d'avancer est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord ou pas parce qu'on peut aussi
dire que il va y avoir là un plan
d'investissement des leviers qui vont se
mettre en fin en à l'oeuvre quoi d'abord
je partage complètement le constat qui
est de dire que effectivement l'éolien
et d'ailleurs quand on regarde bien
petit à petit une bonne partie des
autres énergies renouvelables regardez
l'évolution du discours de Marine Le Pen
juste avant le premier tour de la
présidentielle qui dit éolien puis petit
à petit photovoltaïque et puis j'ouvre
sur la rénovation des bâtiments et puis
j'ouvre sur le véhicule électrique etc
bon donc en fait il y a effectivement
cet enjeu là qui qui est en fait un
espèce de de frein au changement bon
néanmoins quand on veut expliquer du
changement enfin quand on veut
accompagner les personnes en chemin il
faut l'expliquer et là je rejoins
parfaitement à la fois Monsieur le Maire
et madame la sénatrice sur le fait que
aujourd'hui dans la situation dans
lequel on est on a péché voilà sur
l'explication
aussi alors
il y a deux choses nous on est un acteur
qui accompagne la mise en oeuvre d'une
politique publique c'est à dire que on
va accompagner le développement d'une
filière notamment éolienne mais en mer
c'est l'État qui définit les zones et
sur terre c'est l'État qui donne les
permis c'est pas nous qui définissons ou
nous nous mettons bon donc il est
important que l'État qu'il régulateur du
système et une parole claire sur les
énergies renouvelables de manière
générale et sur la transition
énergétiquement mais c'est qu'il était
en l'occurrence
pour les éoliennes sur terre c'est le
préféré localement et pour les éoliennes
en mer pour le coup c'est direct le
ministère de la transition écologique
donc la direction générale de l'énergie
du climat
et il y a un point qui est vraiment
essentiel
là-dessus c'est que là la loi va arriver
et il est essentiel que cette loi ne
soit pas une loi pour ou contre les
énergies renouvelables sinon on passera
à côté de l'enjeu de la transition mais
qui est une loi sur comment on réussit
le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables en France pour pour
mémoire il n'y a aucun autre moyen de
produire de l'électricité entre 2022 et
2035 aucun on ne sait pas produire plus
d'électricité pendant les 15 années qui
arrivent sans autre chose que des
énergies renouvelables s'il y a un mix
énergétique centrale nucléaire énergie
renouvelable
nucléaires qui vont marcher avant 2035
pour le coup juste pour boucler
là-dessus pendant le débat on a
évidemment été écouté les personnes qui
étaient contre les éoliennes et contre
et en fait quand on leur disait mais du
coup qu'est-ce que vous faites il nous
répondait du gaz mais si on décide
aujourd'hui d'un projet de de parc
éolien terrestre il va pas se construire
en 20 minutes ça prend quand même
peut-être un peu moins qu'une centrale
nucléaire mais ça prend quand même temps
aujourd'hui en France il faut à peu près
6 ans bon en Europe
il faut 3 ans d'accord alors on va on va
parler il y a plein de questions qui
restent à aborder dans dans ce débat
notamment effectivement le pouvoir des
mers le zonage c'est-à-dire dans la quel
endroit d'une commune on décide
d'installer ou non les éoliennes et il y
a donc ce cette loi qui arrive propose à
Audrey beta de nous rejoindre tout de
suite rebonsoir Audrey donc texte du
Gouvernement pour accélérer sur les
renouvelables et donc sur l'éolien qui
est examiné au Sénat la semaine
prochaine alors il y a des amendements
déposés par certains sénateurs LR qui
risquent de poser problème
expliquez-nous oui le premier devrait
permettre aux conseils municipaux
d'avoir un droit de blocage ou de veto
contre l'implantation d'éoliennes il
faudrait aussi
de toutes les communes concernées par le
projet pour qu'ils puissent se faire
vous voyez on est plus sur un coup de
frein qu'un coup d'accélérateur autre
idée d'une vingtaine de sénateurs LR il
propose de laisser la possibilité aux
régions d'augmenter la distance minimum
de 500 mètres qui doit séparer un Mad
éolienne d'une zone habitée pour
défendre leur amendement les sénateurs
socialistes les sénateurs pas social du
tout disent travailler à une meilleure
acceptation de ces éoliennes par les
élus locaux on le sait c'est un sujet
qui exacerbe les tensions beaucoup de
mer s'inquiètent des nuisances que cela
peut causer sur leur territoire et ce
n'est pas la première fois que c'est
sénateurs tentent de faire passer un tel
amendement non ils ont déjà essayé de
faire passer deux fois ce droit de veto
des mers lors du précédent quinquennat
lors du projet de loi sur la
décentralisation et plus raisonnant sur
le projet de loi climat vous étiez tout
à fait contre Monsieur Dantec écoutez
leurs arguments par la voix du sénateur
les républicains Didier mandelis était
en 2021
sans doute que nous avons eu un effet
balancier beaucoup trop important avec
un développement anarchique de des
éoliennes sans aucune concertation sans
que les élus locaux puissent dire leurs
mots sur sur ces implantations
potentielles et moi le paysage c'est un
patrimoine commun naturel que chacun
d'entre nous doit pouvoir apprécier à
l'époque le gouvernement n'y était déjà
pas du tout favorable écoutez
si on donne des droits de veto
ça veut dire que quelque part on incite
pas à cette concertation et au fait
qu'on trouve des solutions ensemble un
droit de veto ça peut entraîner alors
dans certains endroits ça va bien se
passer mais dans d'autres endroits ça
peut entraîner tout simplement de d'une
inBe c'est à dire pas chez moi des
amendements qui ont toujours été
retoqués en dernière lecture par
l'Assemblée nationale oui mais voilà
cette année le gouvernement n'a plus de
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée je vous
apprends rien et il va donc falloir
aller chercher les voies DLR peut-être
trouver un juste milieu entre le coup de
frein et le coût d'accélérateur merci
Audrey Nimbi pour note in my backyard
effectivement pas de ça chez moi
Jean-Marie virly est-ce que vous voulez
d'un droit de veto vous par exemple pour
décider ou pas d'installer des éoliennes
sur votre commune ou alors d'empêcher la
commune voisine d'en installer
à droite de veto c'est toujours un peu
compliqué parce que enfin définir les
limites a priori ce que l'on souhaite
nous c'est deux trucs fondamentaux le
premier c'est que on nous explique
pourquoi il faut mettre des éoliennes et
que nous l'explique de façon à ce que on
le comprenne et je vais vous donner des
exemples comme par rapport à ça et
deuxième point c'est que on souhaite
avoir et au moins concerté et qu'on
imagine une entité qui puisse permettre
de dire que là non c'est non alors je
vais donner des exemples très concrets
aujourd'hui sur My commune on dit qu'on
a le pouvoir sur les éoliennes moi
j'interdis toute construction de plus de
15 mètres et il y a des gens qui
viennent me mettre un truc de 240 mètres
à côté de chez moi c'est quand même un
petit peu un petit peu bizarre le
deuxième point c'est que le mitage et
puis surtout le nombre d'éoliennes qui
poussent tout partout dans notre secteur
montre les gens contre la répartition
des éoliennes sur la répartition
nationale et puis après si on réfléchit
ici on essaie de nous expliquer et qu'on
me demande pourquoi à quoi servent les
éoliennes alors nous dit c'est les
éoliennes bien évidemment c'est pour
produire de l'électricité correspondant
et là tout le monde comprend aujourd'hui
y compris ces derniers mois que
l'Allemagne qui a mis quatre fois plus
d'éolienne que nous sur son territoire
aujourd'hui il y a des problèmes
d'électricité donc vous voyez que c'est
vrai que ce que je vous dis est au
premier degré mais le premier degré a du
sens ici heureusement alors après on
nous expliquait et là on nous expliquait
longuement nous prenons les gens de la
campagne un peu pour des tordus de dire
qu'il faut limiter les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre or en parallèle on nous
explique que de mettre des éoliennes et
de l'intermittence ça va permis
d'économiser des tonnes de gaz de
toxiques de toxiques de carbone oui mais
sauf que on nous a jamais dit par
rapport à quoi on compare que les gens
aujourd'hui ont tous internet ils
comprennent bien que si c'est pour
mettre des éoliennes pour remplacer du
nucléaire on va pas très bien ce qu'on
gagne a priori alors je vous redonne la
parole dans un instant j'essaye de faire
en sorte que tout le monde puisse parler
et que les temps de parole soit pas trop
trop long merci beaucoup Jean-Marie
verlis qui est intéressant quand même
on en revient à ce que vous disiez les
uns les autres c'est une sorte de
confusion des esprits ça c'est moi c'est
ce que je c'est ce que je retiens il y a
parce que quoi il y a pas de il y a pas
de consensus scientifique en fait si en
fait c'est le débat politique en France
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de débat
politique structuré en France quel que
soit le sujet où on est dans un monde
d'affirmation on peut dire blanc noir et
comme effectivement il y a pas de juge
de paix pour dire bah non là c'est blanc
ou là c'est noir ou là c'est bleu et le
débat sur l'éolien était terrifiant ce
qu'on entend tout et n'importe quoi et
donc on n'arrive pas je crois
aujourd'hui avoir des débats politiques
un peu
structuré avec des éléments assez
simples le prix par exemple c'est quand
même simple aujourd'hui le bouclier
tarifaire français y compris demain le
bouclier tarifaire pour les petites
collectivités qui ont des prix d'énergie
multipliée par trois ou par 4 et payer
par les énergies renouvelables puisque
les énergies renouvelables aujourd'hui
vont sur le marché marché à 200 300 400
euros alors qu'elles ont des contrats
parlent Commission de régulation à 70 80
euros mais le reste les 200 300 euros
sont reversés à l'état qui le dit c'est
des milliards aujourd'hui qui sont
reversés à l'état et finalement le
bouquet est arrivé c'est le renouvelable
qui le paye ça c'est un fait simple et
là les flux financiers sont posés à
tracés on le dit pas mais je crois quand
même que
il y a des points il faut écouter
effectivement il y a ceux qui sont
contre le développement des
renouvelables parce que il y a un dogme
nucléaire et ce et le lobby nucléaire
s'est battu en France mais depuis des
années 70 contre le développement des
renouvelables ce qui fait qu'on a cumulé
beaucoup de retard et là il y a une
responsabilité effectivement de se lobby
nucléaire mais je crois qu'effectivement
le mode de développement de l'éolien a
fait que finalement l'État n'a pas pris
ses responsabilités planification pour
la même raison c'est à dire que on ne
pouvait c'est la première loi où on
assume de dire la seule solution pour la
France pour garder son industrie pour
les ménages ne paye pas très très cher
leur électricité c'est le renouvelable
c'est la première fois mais du coup
comme il y a pas eu de planification
parce que l'État n'assumait pas le
développement du renouvelable ne voulait
pas le dire et ben c'est c'est les
développeurs alors qui était en
concurrence et on a effectivement un
déséquilibre d'implantation sur le
territoire et ses arguments mais mais
quand même dans le il y a quand même
énormément de témoignages de mère qui
raconte que dans la commune d'à côté il
y a des éoliennes qui ont été installés
je me tourne vers vous Françoise Gatel
et que finalement ce qui les voit ce
sont les habitants de de la commune où
il y a pas d'éoliennes c'est c'est une
réalité ça donc ça pose la question du
zonage est quand même j'y reviens du
droit de veto un est-ce que vous y êtes
favorable à ce droit des taux est deux
si vous y êtes pas favorable qu'est-ce
qu'on met à la place quoi ben on a déjà
répondu à cette question enfin je veux
dire il existe dans une loi qui
s'appelle 3DS qui est très récente une
solution qui je crois après le
diagnostic jusque de monsieur mondelli a
porté la solution et je rappelle qu'on a
eu un embryon de planification qui était
assez remarquable et qui a disparu
c'était l'obligation dans les schémas de
cohérence territoriale donc ces
documents d'urbanisme et une échelle 20
30 ou 50 communes de fer un zonage de
l'éolien Seigneur
la production de l'éolienne l'efficacité
du vent et on devrait avoir ça dans nos
documents tout ça ça a disparu et
ensuite on a un vrai sujet c'est à dire
qu'effectivement le droit de veto du
maire c'est très gentil c'est le maire
sur la commune duquel vient s'installer
l'éolienne mais qui va brasser de l'air
si je puis dire excusez-moi sur la
commune voisine donc ça énerve tout le
monde mais que la réponse c'est pas le
véto parce que le veto ça veut dire que
le maire il se prend une responsabilité
le pauvre malheureux il se retrouve
entre les pour et les contes donc il est
sûr de prendre des coups et ensuite
juridiquement qu'est-ce qui se passe au
tribunal quand le promoteur il va faire
un recours le juge dit oui un véto du
maire mais on sait pas pourquoi donc ça
ne tient pas et nous à retrouver une
solution les compétences techniques où
on leur donne pas forcement d'éléments
pour pouvoir dire je mets un véto ou pas
quoi c'est une fausse bonne idée tu dis
on fait peser sur le maire un truc et
sincèrement on a déjà trouvé une idée ça
existe dans le texte 3DS puisqu'il y
avait déjà cette histoire de Vito et on
a trouvé une solution qui est un truc
que moi je trouve bien alors c'est à
l'échelle de la commune ou de l'interco
ça n'empêche pas le volet stratégique de
développement mais il y a un truc tout
bête qui est le maire ou le président de
l'interco à la compétence en matière
d'urbanisme il décide d'entreprendre une
procédure très simple c'est une
modification simplifiée de son document
d'urbanisme ça prend six mois
et vous avez une concertation parce
qu'il y a une enquête publique donc vous
avez un commissaire enquêteur vous
consultez les communes voisines et vous
définissez sur le territoire de votre
commune là vous pouvez mettre de
l'éolien moi ça me semble être beaucoup
plus sécurisant qu'un droit de veto vous
mettez entre les mers une arme à feu qui
se retourne contre lui donc mais ça
existe dans la loi j'ai une question
tout le territoire mais ce qu'il faut
pas surtout les mettre là où il y a du
vent ou est-ce que maintenant c'est une
question
la question c'est une très bonne
question nous ce qu'on pousse pour le
coup c'est plusieurs choses premièrement
on dit en fait il faut
beaucoup plus largement que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui ouvrir des zones au
développement de l'éolien en
hiérarchisant les enjeux dans différents
endroits pour éviter les phénomènes de
concentration ça quel que soit les
énergies renouvelables desquelles on
parle photovoltaïque éolien
méthanisation à partir du moment où vous
avez des phénomènes de concentration à
un endroit donné vous avez des
phénomènes de rejet bon ça c'est ce
qu'on apprend de 20 ans de politique
énergétiques en France autour des
énergies renouvelables bon donc on l'a
appris on l'a compris du coup maintenant
ouvrons l'espace premier sujet deuxième
sujet il y a des mécanismes citatifs qui
permettent de dire écoutez nous on vous
encourage à vous mettre un endroit où il
y a effectivement un peu moins de vent
mais avec des éoliennes d'aujourd'hui on
est capable de produire avec un tarif
dit de complément de rémunération
peut-être un peu plus élevé pour
équilibrer votre projet nous ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on pousse à qu'on
dit écoutez il faut sortir de ces
phénomènes de concentration voilà donc
c'est aujourd'hui c'est pas dans la loi
parce que manifestement on peut le faire
avec pas besoin de législatif on peut le
faire avec des un cadre réglementaire
allons-y fonçons et dernier sujet qui
est vraiment essentiel pour le coup dans
tous ces débats sur est-ce qu'il faut
des enrh pas de NR du nucléaire pas
nucléaire etc il y a un travail
extraordinaire qui a été fait par RTE
RTE il y a un an assorti un travail
extraordinaire si scénarios pour
permettre à la France d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone bon c'est si scénario
il vous donne le champ des possibles et
tous vous dites vous disent quel que
soit le
ceux qui sont aussi c'est que
aujourd'hui la connaissance un peu
évoluée et ils sont hostiles parce que
ils comprennent pas pourquoi on en met à
quoi ça sert je répète c'est là
aujourd'hui on est un certain nombre à
imaginer que c'est inutile de remettre
des éoliennes terrestres en ce moment en
France comme tenu de leur intermittence
le deuxième élément c'est le paysage il
faut que les gens de la ville je suis un
peu dur mais il faut que les gens de la
ville comprennent ce qu'est le paysage
paysage alors dans nos territoires sur
les dans les terres la caractéristique
principale du paysage c'est le calme
sérénité mettre des éléments qui bougent
tout le temps dans un espace qui est
dont la caractérise principale et la
sérénité forcément comme le disait tout
à l'heure dans le reportage ce paysage
le paysage est chamboulé et la vie est
chamboulée on préfère nous entendre
siffler le vent dans les feuilles que
d'entendre le vent s'y fait dans les
éoliennes c'est tout à fait tout à fait
clair alors s'ajoute en ce moment des
problèmes de santé sur lesquels personne
clairement tout ce qui se passe voilà
donc si vous rajoutez simplement le fait
que on a pas le choix et que on est
quasiment tous les 15 jours sollicités
que on n'est pas sûr que ça servait à
quelque chose que vous venez me dire
qu'il y a des tas de groupes de
réflexion comme le cérémy qui disent que
ça ne sert à rien que c'est pas une
bonne solution de le mettre en terre et
puis le troisième point c'est que on
aimerait bien que les qu'elle soit
imposées autour de nous l'un des
éoliennes ça se voit à 50 km c'est pas
on n'est pas en train de parler de la
dimension d'une commune c'est le
problème de fond il est là c'est à dire
que ça crée des clivages dans les
communes et ça crée des clivages forts
entre les communes sur lesquelles alors
maintenant je rebondis sur ce qu'on
attend parce que à chaque fois vous
faites des interventions qui sont un peu
trop longues je préfère vous interrompre
et vous redonner la parole plusieurs
fois excusez-moi de mener le débat de
façon un peu un petit peu directive
Jean-Marie virlimet je le fais parce que
finalement je vais aller d'une certaine
façon dans votre sens et dans le sens de
des habitants de de la commune des
poisses qui sont inquiets avec l'extrait
d'un documentaire qui a été diffusé il y
a quelques mois sur public Senn j'ai
toujours d'ailleurs disponible en replay
rencontrer pour les mères documentaire
signé Jérôme Rabier alors on est dans la
Somme on est avec le l'ancien maire de
Grécourt qui est agriculteur écoutez le
Didier
village et il a validé les éoliennes
mais c'est aussi lui qui vit au plus
près et désormais il regrette
sous les yeux on se rend pas compte et
enfin moi je pensais pas qu'ils avaient
dépassé mes toitures et tout ça enfin
aujourd'hui donc là vous les voyez de
chez vous depuis l'intérieur de chez
vous
on va me dire faut déplacer votre télé
mais bon moi j'étais là-bas
quand il y a du vent le soir dans la
course et en fait ça fait caisse de
résonance et le bruit reste dans la cour
en fait
à vivre c'est infernal mais le principal
désagrément n'est pas là il y aurait
selon lui un impact sur son élevage
depuis l'implantation des machines à
proximité
oui au début que le parc a été mis en
activité on a eu des problèmes de avec
notamment avec des veaux les tout
premier problème sont venus avec des
veaux qu'ils ont refusé de se nourrir on
a eu quatre vents dans un mois dans le
même mot qui sont laissés mourir de faim
on a une autre
qui sont mortes des vaches adultes qui
sont mortes le même jour moi je fais ça
depuis 18 ans j'en ai 56 j'ai jamais vu
ça j'ai jamais vu ça je pense qu'il faut
que les autres autorités prennent
conscience que
qu'on peut pas monter des projets
soi-disant écologiques et
en contrepartie mettent à mal des
animaux qui qui ont rien demandé mais à
ce jour aucune étude n'a prouvé le lien
entre ces décès l'implantation des
éoliennes alors évidemment la conclusion
de cette séquence de géomie elle est
importante Renan Dantec mais ça rejoint
la question de la santé une vraie
interrogation des riverains quand on
décide d'installer des éoliennes ou pas
est-ce qu'il y a des études qui peuvent
rassurer notre téléspectateurs qui sont
confrontés un truc très simple il y a
des éoliennes un peu partout en France
j'ai pas le sentiment qui avait une
mortalité particulière en France
aujourd'hui
il y a l'éolien non par contre on a non
mais là c'est sur les animaux par
exemple oui on a mais on a des problèmes
dans un certain nombre d'endroits un peu
toujours les mêmes qu'il y ait éolienne
ou pas mais qui sont plutôt liés à des
mauvaises isolations des câbles et donc
ça c'est une responsabilité
et c'est pas lié alors je comprends pas
qui passe électrique
et on a le même problème avec des câbles
qui sont des câbles électriques entre
deux points mais sans qu'il y ait
d'éoliennes donc là je pense qu'on a des
problèmes d'isolation de câble et
effectivement le problème en France et
ça c'est un problème que l'on a connu
dans tous les domaines j'ai même fait
une commission d'enquête sur les grands
projets et on avait toujours la même
chose c'est que on a un problème de
transparence en France on a du mal à
mettre toujours toutes les données sur
Internet y compris des fois le
développeur éolien puisque on avait un
problème de ce type dans une dans une
ferme de Loire-Atlantique et on a mis
très longtemps à obtenir d'éteindre
quelques jours l'éolienne pour voir ce
qui se passait et là aussi l'exploitant
le développeur éolien était en
résistance donc c'est pour dire que on a
aussi quelques cow-boy dans la
profession qui n'ont pas aidé moi j'ai
on a je vais dans le sens de Françoise
Gatel c'est très intéressant Françoise
Gatel parce qu'a priori on peut trouver
une majorité un la semaine prochaine
pour supprimer le droit de veto a priori
si j'entends bien Françoise Gatel ce qui
va simplifier les choses pour la suite
mais en fait le problème effectivement
qu'on a et moi j'ai proposé aussi qu'on
passe par un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt sur les territoires qui assume
de faire leur part mais qui veulent être
concertés en disant on veut bien de
l'éolien proposer nous les projets les
mieux intégrés qui qui finalement capte
si le plus y compris l'épargne locale et
le maire derrière le conseil municipal
peut dire ce projet est est meilleur
donc je crois qu'on est tous assez
d'accord pour dire qu'il y a une marge
de progrès sur l'acceptabilité qui font
répartir au niveau national et régional
mais la programmation pluriel de
l'énergie prévoit de fait aussi des
productions par région qu'il faudra
décliner au niveau des scottes et des
pluies moi je pense qu'on n'est pas très
très loin de trouver l'équilibre et que
cette loi permet
un débat finalement vous êtes un peu
optimiste quand même il y a je suis
toujours mais même pas sûr que
localement tous les éludistes ça et que
politiquement il y a que la droite on
l'a démontré avec Mathieu dit ça quand
même une vraie différence aujourd'hui le
prix de l'électricité dans un centre de
commune a été multiplié par 4 il y a la
crise en Ukraine le gaz n'est plus une
solution et on sait qu'il n'y a que
Mathieu
croissantoine en ville
éloignée un minimum de 50% de 500 m par
exemple en plein milieu de jardin
Luxembourg
si on prend le cas du jardin du
Luxembourg en ville il y a les
incinérateurs qui font les réseaux de
chaleur il y a
pas besoin alors il y a une technologie
il y a une technologie c'est les cubes
qu'on met sur les sur les immeubles
vous aurez pas une danse entre une on
dirait oh là là ça dénature le centre de
Paris il en faut pas au jardin
Luxembourg vous êtes fous vous allez pas
en mettre à côté de Notre-Dame l'hôpital
est en ville il sert aussi rural ça
n'existe pas de dire qu'il y aurait le
milieu rural d'un côté le milieu
s'il vous plaît
moi j'aime son côté ça va le faire
bah oui oui mais bon je veux dire
sincèrement moi je pense que on a encore
une fois on a la vigilance
qu'aujourd'hui on se paye des problèmes
parce qu'on a eu une méthode désordonnée
et on bricole voilà et donc après il
faut remonter le courant donc je pense
qui a cette idée de stratégie il faut
régler toutes les questions et
qu'effectivement moi j'entends votre
question toi tu peux dire ce que tu veux
mais les gens qui habitent un peu
partout ils disent tout ça c'est bien
gentil mais c'est à la campagne qu'on
prend l'eau à la campagne qu'on met les
éoliennes donc nous on sert d'espèces de
grenier d'énergie donc les gens ça les
énerve quand on plus on leur explique
qu'ils peuvent plus rouler leur vieille
voiture non mais la vraie vie c'est ça
aussi maintenant moi je pense qu'on a
aussi d'autres problèmes à régler qui
sont devant nous et je veux pas gâcher
la soirée mais quand on met des
éoliennes sur terre je parle pas de
l'éolien en mer moi j'y suis plutôt
favorable dès lors que c'est bien fait
quand vous venez poser une éolienne il
faut mettre je crois tu me trompes tu me
démentiras si je fais une erreur 1500
tonnes de béton
d'accord pour tenir l'éolienne donc 15
ans qu'est-ce qu'on va en faire oui
alors dans 15 ans il va falloir démonter
tout ça donc j'espère que la société qui
a implanté l'éolienne elle sera toujours
là dans 15 ans d'accord pour démonter
tout ça il sera pas chargé comme une et
enfin on cherche là on va plus être
d'accord du tout c'est que on a atteint
de ce dont on parle qui est important on
a un autre sujet qui le zéro
artificialisation nette et on nous dit
vous arrêtez d'aller camper dans les
terres agricoles parfait sauf que et si
vous artificialisez vous devez produire
autant de terre de nature et il se
trouve sauf erreur de ma part que les
éoliennes avec leur emprise sur Terre et
leur 1500 tonnes de béton ce n'est pas
considéré comme de l'artiste qui peut
répondre à ça est-ce que c'est de
l'artificealisation des terres 1 et 2 et
2 qu'est-ce qu'on en fera à la fin de
vie des éoliennes
plusieurs sujets rapidement parce qu'il
nous reste deux minutes premièrement sur
les fondations d'une éolienne une
éolienne en terme de fondation c'est
l'équivalent des fondations de deux
maisons bon donc ça donne ça donne un
ordre de grandeur quand on regarde le
nombre en Île-de-France ont construit 70
000 logements par an donc en fait quand
on regarde ce que ça représente il y a
8000 yens en France aujourd'hui c'est
marginal en termes bon les déchets du
BTP donc le béton notamment ce qu'on
appelle des déchets inert donc en fait
vous démontez votre lien ce qui se passe
vous êtes dans le Finistère vous allez
autour de Perpignan etc vous démontrez
votre éolienne vous grattez le sol vous
faites vos concoint c'est ça vous mettez
ça en sous-couche de route ce sont des
déchets qui sont inertes donc il ne se
transforment pas qui rendent pas des
nappes phréatiques etc etc et vous
remettez d'altère végétalisée est-ce que
les entreprises s'engagent à le faire
enfin c'est la loi c'est la loi c'est
prévu dans la loi il y a des dotations
et une éolienne c'est un mode de
production d'électricité c'est un
équipement industriel donc ça appartient
à quelqu'un
ça se vend ça se rachète etc mais ça
appartient à quelqu'un aujourd'hui en
France il y a pas d'éoliennes ça
n'existe pas en fait c'est un mode de
production d'électricité et d'ailleurs
au prix auquel aujourd'hui électricité
c'est un mode de production dont tout
intérêt à posséder donc il y a ce jour
il y a pas de sujets avec ça
néanmoins-moi au dernier mot pour le
coup là où je pense que c'est vraiment
très important il faut avancer sur
rappeler que pas de transition sans
énergie renouvelable et notamment sans
éolien en ce moment en France on aurait
encore plus de difficultés si on n'avait
pas d'énergie renouvelable l'éolien
c'est 8% ce week-end c'était 20% de
notre consommation d'électricité
l'éolien donc vous rendez compte dans
quelle situation on serait sans ça et
par contre là où c'est très clair c'est
qu'il faut faire évoluer la méthode pour
donner de la visibilité mieux répartir
on l'a compris et partager et on l'a
déjà dit merci beaucoup partagé bénéfice
c'était une des thématiques que je
voulais aborder ce sera pour une autre
fois merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat ici en plateau et depuis et poids
c'est évidemment à bientôt sur Public
Sénat voilà je vous donne rendez-vous
demain évidemment 18h et 22h pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public d'ici là
la matinale Oriane Mancini qui reçoit
demain matin Jean-Philippe Tanguy le
député RN de la Somme belle soirée à
toutes et à tous